yes my only beak cane however Arab
to
benefit from the nobel peace prize
is to be invested with a mission
that is to say not to convey peace the
ideas of peace wherever
possible europe does not  was not done we had
the war europe will not be done all at
once it will be done by concrete achievements
is this mysterious 20 years on russian
what makes you write china that is
a big problem before towards a
third big party
why did I that in reality we
wanted to make europe after the
second world war
blatter that it is beautiful he you know
this first common market
these premieres of
supranational institutions l europe
he comments in tunis
the tv during the pass to you as the
crucial and long-term factor to bring
the economy to the end yassine girl because
the man has nevertheless returned you a
little
wonder what europe was
still 50 years ago
at the moment  solidarity is perhaps
a bit put  strained but suddenly
yes it's true that it is perhaps much
better to remember that we
unlike our parents
grandparents before not known war
mohamed allouche brand heineken in
europe 1 nevertheless europeans a
diverse range risks  of a double income
on family and you drop is bond
europe is perfect for us it is
made for all european countries
open our arms these countries
it's wonderful it's our heart that speaks
good i normand
i i  had no naval boring and may 1st
2004 i was with all those who
were is better seen school because it
was a symbolic moment our
return to the community of peoples
he avoids puts in his place
trish godman part of my bra
push up  world has shown that
in October to politics
nice shock on Saturday nor acquired
a contract I have the stream it is the
candidate of young people and railway families
Jean Cocteau
for example the diet
the evening bandas date no longer has  good  in
shediac facebook beauty on the bench we
can never remember enough how much
this peace now taking root there
constituted a revolution compared to
a history enamelled over the centuries
of incessant conflicts dramatic
bloody I fear lausanne
libero not